as much as we see bad headlines like
this there's actually a silver lining
for small business owners which is that
really good talent is now back available
on the market at reasonable rates now
the thing that you should watch out for
is if there's a structural layoff as the
reason someone went down then they means
that they were the bottom 10 so take an
extra hard look at those people but
companies that cut like an entire
department like no more recruiting
because we're not hiring there's tons of
great people in those layoffs so keep an
eye open because I think there's going
to be great Buys in terms of talent in
the next 24 months